positional
the group is beginning to assemble
there were already been prepared
with the use of proper tony materials
for the film which is traditional
the projector is in place
the screen
and the speaker
are set up
the amplifier is properly fed up
and the court connected to the project
the power cord it properly connected
both to the projector
and to the outside
the light control curtains are ready to
be drawn
an assistant to the polite which
it is time to start
the production is given signal on the
curtains are close
the assistant turns out the light
and the show has begun
everything properly prepared in advance
and georgia good film showing
good film shows are set up in advance
so that there is a time to remedy any
faults that would otherwise martha show
in this room film will be shown shortly
the production is arrives early
so that he will have time to set up is
equipment
and check the light control facilities
the ventilation
the park towers
is on the quibbling and the films to be
shocked
is already made sure that the power
supply is the right time
alternating more direct current
and that it is the right voltage for the
project
the screen and set up in the front of
the room
it is placed so that everyone can hear
the lease date
the bottom of the screen should be level
with the tops of the heads of those in
the front rule
the projector is on a stack
the standard directly in front of the
screen
so that there will be no list five wise
distortion of the projected in
the projector arms are put in place
the take-out belt is correct
the bar card too plugged into the
projector is good to put a period of the
project is down
to prevent the projector from being
tipped over at the court is full
when an extension cord is needed the
projection is twist to the chords around
one another before putting them together
so that the court uphold or object
they will not come apart
to the court is wrapped around of
germany
it is plugged into a wall of
and the export is called up neatly
against a wall
the projector is turned on for a trial
run
break-the-mold
than the left
the image is too large for the screen
because the projector is too far away
the average thirty foot classroom
an image of about three and one half
feet wide is best
with the standard length this will
result in the projector is about twenty
feet from the screen
if the projector is closer to the screen
image will be smaller into bright
if the projector is farther away from
the premium it will be larger and to do
therefore if the images to mark the
projector must be moved closer to the
screen
the image is not the right side and
brilliant but it was around it
with is dead in the aperture of the
projector which was the catholic cleaned
before the showing for the date is not
only disturbing to speak
but it looks crash the bill
after the visual projection has been
checked
the sound is connected
so that it to can be inspected
some speakers have their own power
supply
and the court listed plugged into a wall
outlets
the speaker court is also anchored to
the lake of the table
it is anchored again to the leg of the
project is down before it is connected
to the projector
now the amplifier is turned off
in a few moments ago the warmed up when
the bottom control it end up full
allotment will search to indicate that
the sound system is working
remember that there will be less volume
and left my frequently response
in a room filled with the audience and
then empty room
so the bottom of the phone should be
done somewhat higher in the proprietor
of production
the films are placed in the order of
their projection
began to be opened unplugged open
so the changes of real condemn it
quickly without interruptions while at
the game it has been palermo
to determine whether the film is ready
for bed
that the film off the real over the top
making sure that it doesn't get on the
floor where it will pick up date and
scratches
warning the end of the film straight up
in the air at the picture or letters are
right side up
and in the correct left to right
position
the film is ready for friday
when the scholberg and you won't have
this
the picture will be right side up
and in the proper position
all the rails that ought to be protected
should be inspected in that matter
when the president on the first film on
the program should be printed in the
project
after threatening the motor trend up
then the lapd
the images focused and brought into
proper frame
remember that on phone projectors thus
far wields labs for kids only on one
side
because don't films out barbara pulls
only on one side
the sound runs on the other
more silent projectors are focused on
both eyes of the sprocket wheel
silent film conveyed on amazon projector
but some films must never be run
unemployment machine
to refuse the strain on the film during
projection
the film is threaded with lou
above
and below the gate
if the loops are too short they will
tear the film
if they are too large they will flap
about
the correct size as indicated on the
projector itself
check to see if there's an their
projection lamp
affair is like a man for the phone
system of the therapy was to the
amplifier
make sure that the amplifier and the
park order in the best position
checked the light control pistol-whipped
draw curtains were improperly installed
provide the most effective light
controlled media
the clinton should be hung in such a way
that the hangars run along the track
the rod and bring method will not stand
up to long where
the track should be fixed to the feeling
far enough away from the wall so that
the curtain will avoid obstruction
such as window boxes bookshelves
radiators or windows that open in words
like this
the bottom of the curtain should be
about eighteen inches from the floor
this will control the light
but permit ventilation
here the curtain operates mostly and
dark and effectively
the track for one carton cards around
the end of the other
they don't overlap
and no gap is present to permit the
entry of mine
everything has now been checked for my
controlled as the motives of the film
the projector and the amplifier
the production is arrived early enough
to make sure that all would be working
well
now that the group is coming in here the
short himself at the show will be good
there will be no fault or interruptions
tomorrow
and attention to the bill than the
enjoyment of it
will be understood
when the show is over
the room lights are turned on well the
entitlement still on the screen
the projector lamp is then turned off
has been at the found on the bill to
finish the amplifier is turned off
if at all possible dismantling or
removal could not take place until after
the audience at this point
careful preparation
produces except for short